nach dem schweren unwetter am wochenende
in allein zeigt sich am montag das
ausmaß der überflutung verwüstete
wohnungen und geschäfte wo man hinschaut
auch die städtische infrastruktur oder
nicht verschont der schaden ist enorm
am samstag ist der grossbank über die
ufer getreten das ist zu mehreren
vermurungen kaum eines hot dann auch
noch drei pkw indem kubach
hineingerissen dadurch sind die
verglasungen noch stärker geworden und
es haben große teile der halleiner
altstadt überflutet
es sind mehrere muren abgegangen
gesamten gemeindegebiet am dürrnberg
gibt es enorme schäden wurden abgänge
gibt es aber auch von kalten aus und
biss nachgaben
und so wurde auch das bundesheer um
hilfe ersucht 67 soldaten sind im
einsatz und helfen vor ort bei den
aufräumarbeiten
das betont 2 wurde am sonntag um 06 25
alarmiert und haben wir haben noch die
präsidentin kompanie formiert die ersten
erkundungsflug sind um sieben und 15
richtung hallein gefahren und mit mit
der ersten vor ort waren um 12 uhr hier
in einem einsatz in hallein
wir haben noch bis 14 uhr die kräfte
aufstocken können und derzeit sind wir
mit 66 soldaten im einsatz die arbeiten
wird sicher noch andauern wobei es
fraglich ist wie lange die prämie noch
im einsatz sind wir sind auf jeden fall
so lange hier
solange es die einsatzkräfte brauchen
auch verteidigungsministerin klaudia
tanner macht sich vor ort in allein ein
bild der lage
ich muss sagen einfach betroffen wenn
man das sieht es ist noch schlimmer als
die bilder die über das fernsehen
vermittelt werden
gut ist dass unsere soldaten draußen des
hermann auch von den betroffenen und
mithelfen können ist zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt 667 soldaten im einsatz und
die bleiben auch so lange so lange das
notwendig ist ein ganz großes dankeschön
an die einsatzkräfte an alle
einsatzkräfte aber besonders an unsere
soldaten die so wichtige arbeit leisten
[Musik]